we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got surf set white eyed tabata
yoga and boot camp it's your body
this is fighting I am will and this is
to bottom Tabata is an I intensity
interval training protocol that our
professor in Japan came up with in 1996
he created this 20 seconds of work 10
seconds of rest over 8 rounds spoda can
incorporate anything across the board
you can do with push-ups about a burpees
Tabata situps
well CrossFit is done is they've taken
the tabata a timing protocol and taken
it into their bag of tricks Oh what do
we have we have 4 minutes what can we do
where can we increase this athletes
aerobic activity and actually it will
increase your anaerobic activity as well
because we'll throw in weighted
activities I really love Tabata because
it's short and sweet and get in get done
and feel like I've actually had a
workout try to bhatta and get moving
this is your at-home
Tabata upper-body workout we've got an
upper body Tabata which is gonna focus
movements on our chest shoulders and
back okay the first is the hand release
pushup now the handle is push-up I like
to do because it forces you to get the
entire range of motion of push-up we
start at the top in the plank you lower
your body all the way to the floor okay
man's gotta superset that with the
dumbbell push press for the push press
you'll clean them up to your shoulders
you notice the weights are pointing
directly forward I'm gonna do a little
dip in my knee and drive the weight up
and down so you want to cycle through as
many as you can so you'll start with 20
seconds of hand release push-ups will
rest for 10 seconds to pick up your
weights 20 seconds of dumbbell push
press 4 rounds of that cycle ok yeah
it's good a shot all right here we go
get that thing started in 3 2 1 go
- yeah you definitely feel that stretch
down at the bottom there you have ten
seconds of rest
so grab your dumbbells it's basically
your transition time three two one dip
Drive squeeze good try to get them a
little closer together at the top one
you can drop your weights okay
back down two hand release push ups one
good good
ready go as fast as you can you wanna
get as many reps as possible to 110
seconds of rest all right crank through
these up back down and up good on that
shoulder burn oh yeah in three two one
cool awesome so that's two full rounds
of Tabata - it's just - yeah so double
it you have your full four rounds it's
about it maybe done okay how do you know
Phil and go ahead in four rounds is
gonna be a little bit tough I'm not
gonna lie but yeah I like being pushed
no you did great man thanks man so recap
guys this is your upper body Tabata
workout we started off with 20 seconds
of hand release push-ups we're going to
10 seconds of rest 20 seconds of the
dumbbell push press 10 seconds to rest
you repeat that four times for your
complete upper body Tabata workout if
you guys want to take it to the next
level you can go hit up my man will at
brick New York calm now get that right
yes there thank you for putting me
through that right there this is good
stuff I like it
stay tuned make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any other fighting
weight episodes